hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
off pop and gone um by flight
reacts which is another reaction channel
on youtube
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and let me know
in the comments what video you'd like me
to react to
next okay
[Music]
okay so when he says he's popping off
that's like a term for doing well
right so he's doing well in life
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so he's detailing different positions
that he's gonna hook up with these girls
in so he said from the back
from the front he's letting him know i
can do it in a lot of different
positions i can pull up
[ __ ] ride the dick like a [ __ ]
solo [ __ ] with a beverage
slim [ __ ] i just [ __ ] that worth little
[Music]
from the windows
[Music]
wow she does not have a lot of clothes
on um
a lot of women
he does not look that tall i'm not gonna
lie he looks kind of tall i would guess
[Music]
i like that he's taking all these verses
from all these different songs that
we've been like popular
i'm off my grind so you know i'm
finished
nothing else but them dollar signs baby
i know that you wanna be mine
but i'm a big baller cannot waste no
time [ __ ] a g
wagon this ain't no rover ftc really
bout to take over smoking on gas
cause i'm a stoner i make the paper you
make the turnover why y'all want the hot
[ __ ] call me nike do it i'm a trending
top again ain't really nothing to it
hearing what they got but i never see
them shoot it claiming use a drug deal a
[ __ ] who you fooling
okay so he's saying you said that you're
a drug dealer but you're not actually a
drug dealer you're just playing
but his drug dealer wouldn't have a lot
of money so how would you pretend to be
a drug dealer
let me know but i never see you moving
[ __ ] on this [ __ ] then i clear how
i'm moving
throw that ass back go and show them how
you do
[Music]
ten
[Music]
so he's saying that he's doing well in
life and the haters
want him to be gone like they're just
they're over
i think you better move on cause [ __ ]
i'm
[Music]
he could sing that song about not having
to type because these girls
have you ever thought about how none of
these
dance moves like they would look very
weird if the sound wasn't going
um i actually really liked the song like
even outside of um like just these
reactions like i'd give that song a 10.
i really enjoyed all the throwbacks to
songs that like i heard when i was
growing up
yeah so 10 out of 10 for me and let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
with me or you disagree with me
and let me know what i should react to
next time